[Aplausos]
[Música]
ama menor é um lixo mesmo em make the
rocks mk médico
a terminar e do mediterrâneo e john
montorio minha bebê que mama se aprender
alguma coisa então eu vou traduzir o que
acabei de falar estava cumprimentando
dizendo amigos como estão
vou hoje compartilhar uma pequena
partícula da minha pesquisa e minha
preocupação com vocês para que nós
possamos planejar algo pra nós podermos
fazer acontecer
então a gente
essa é a língua que eu defendo
eu defendo preserva e me considero um
guardião da história de um povo indígena
sou membro desta comunidade falante
nativo
então vou falar um pouco sobre o o ou a
minha preocupação que na verdade não é
minha área de de pesquisa sobre o uso de
tecnologia e à comunidade indígena
na verdade eu sou a minha área de
pesquisa é diferente é de ciências
humanas ciências da linguagem mas ao
longo do tempo de convivência enquanto
membro de um povo
eu considerei isso e eu vejo que é
preocupante
isso manter vivo uma cultura
tá que tá sendo gradativamente agredida
ao longo da história brasileira
então a minha preocupação hoje talvez é
falar uma língua indígena manter vivo
talvez não é comum e isso em um programa
dessa natureza mas eu acredito que é
dessa maneira é que nós podemos pensar
num caminho de como manter vivo uma
cultura indígena
ao longo da história de com brasileira
está a cultura indígena ela foi agredida
gradativamente os povos indígena foro é
tentado aculturar ao longo dos 500 anos
mas houve uma resistência muito grande
dos povos indígenas
mas ao longo da história tá também
quando eu falo em agressão
uma das coisas foi primeiramente
aculturar os povos indígenas a inserir
falar uma língua padronizar a língua a
cultura no sentido também de catequizar
porque acreditava que são povos que não
tinha alma não pagam os a então isso foi
ao longo da história dos povos indígenas
e quando eu falo sobre o uso da
tecnologia de maneira sustentável
vejo que isso ao longo da da história
dos povos indígena
ele vem os 500 anos de contato está
agredindo tão rapidamente e isso é muito
preocupante enquanto o pesquisador e ver
isso ao longo desse de contato ao longo
de palestras que eu participei em vários
alguns estados
tá e vejo isso jovens pesquisadores
indígenas falando na mesma linguagem que
estou falando hoje
então isso é preocupante ver que um
ovo que ao longo da história é é
repassava todo o conhecimento através da
oralidade aonde os jovem conversava com
os anos se homs e que isso foi foi
deixado de lado
então na atualidade
hoje tá ao longo da história desde jovem
gente
uma das coisas que eu quero deixar claro
para o público hoje é de que a língua de
mim a comunicação é a língua portuguesa
por necessidade
tanto que o que eu quero dizer não estou
preocupado hoje falar um português
acadêmico repassar para o povo
o meu conhecimento a minha preocupação a
minha preocupação hoje é fazer com que
nós aqui você seja que compreenda a
minha preocupação através da minha
comunicação que a língua portuguesa pra
mim é uma língua estrangeira
eu aprendi falar a língua português
quando com 15 anos de idade com muita
dificuldade eu aprendi então por
necessidade vendo isso ao longo do tempo
desde pequeno eu fui vendo isso e tão
jovem comecei a fazer uma pesquisa e se
preocupar nos anos 90 já o nos anos 80 e
início dos anos 80 eu fui vendo 90 houve
essa preocupação se partiu de mim o que
eu poderia fazer é conscientes a
conscientiza os jovens porque manteve
uma cultura porque vivo manter a língua
a nossa língua viva porque porque a
nossa língua está sendo substituída por
uma outra língua estrangeira
então isso fez com que eu buscasse é é
eu vi que uma das ferramentas que seria
é um conhecimento acadêmico que hoje eu
considero que é uma fera
lenta porque quando se faz qualquer
pesquisas pesquisa acadêmico gil não
indígena é é aquele cara um grande
pesquisador
mas quando se trata de um pesquisador
indígena
ele precisa ter um título acadêmico isso
fez com que buscassem então eu vou
buscar o conhecimento na academia
sociólogo vi que não era aquilo que eu
queria pois está preocupado com uma
língua
tá então fui na área da linguagem
hoje a minha formação de preservar a
língua de registrar essa língua só
linguiça
o mestre e doutora em linguística
atualmente sou eu tenho uma formação em
pós doutorado em política linguística
então esse seria eu vendo os jovens
substituindo está a tecnologia ataque
tanto que eles não conversa mais com
sábio ancião sentindo-se vergonha na
qualidade de indígena de falar sua
língua materna se manter vivo sua
cultura deixar de lado os seus costumes
então é isso que eu fiz pra poder
conscientiza e hoje sou eu sou o único
pesquisador essa área da linguagem desta
língua na qual e acabei acabei de falar
que você só ouvindo então a minha
preocupação hoje como acabei de falar
sobre assistir a substituição sobre a
agressão
tá aonde os jovens só deixando é de usar
uma tradição oral substituindo isso a
tecnologia de maneira se é tão agressiva
sem planejamento
tá e que foi tá sendo substituído tão
rápido
então hoje eu gostaria de ir
e se essa minha preocupação e fazer um
convite altere rio do sul para que nós
pudéssemos pensar junto a de que forma
nós podemos podemos fazer é evitar com
que umas culturas indígena eu não estou
falando do meu povo só mas de culturas
indígenas brasileira porque em várias
palestras como acabei de falar
participei de bancas de mestrado e
doutorado a onde vários povos indígenas
jovens pesquisadores falando essa
linguagem
então a minha preocupação é o hoje o que
é que nós vamos pensar usar essa mesma
tecnologia que está agredindo
gradativamente a cultura indígena para
poder registrar a língua a história de
um de um povo que os jovens não tô mais
interessando a conversar com os anciões
então que tipo de programa nós vamos
fazer para que esses jovens que usa tão
tão total a ser preocupado mesmo com
digamos já se a tecnologia de informação
que no caso seria a internet não há mais
conversa um exemplo vivo que eu tenho
tenho três filhos
eles não converso mais comigo de várias
pesquisas eu sou um pesquisador e eles
às vezes muitas vezes eles me pergunta
no quarto para o que nós vamos fazer
hoje o que nós vamos comer hoje ou às
vezes é certa porque os três estudam
hoje eles estudam na universidade
federal de santa catarina inclusive eu
sou professor da universidade federal de
santa catarina
então lá eles dentro da da minha casa o
pai é preciso saber isso
então esse é preocupa eu vivo isso
presente se isso no meu dia a dia
então de que forma nós vamos nos dar
essa esse mesmo mecanismo eu acredito
que temos que usar esse mesmo mecanismo
que fez com que a aaa nota geração está
deixando sua cultura de lá vamos a isso
eu estou convidando pra que nós temos um
parceiro fazer parceria para nós
podermos pensar de que forma se
registrar isso a língua então enquanto
principalmente a língua eu considero que
a língua uma língua ela e dna da pessoa
eu não posso dizer que perdeu são um
povo determinada etnia disse a minha
língua materna ou a língua daquele povo
eu não sei falar o mesmo saiu de goya o
pt sutton pertencia meus ancestrais são
isso
então para evitar isso eu acredito que é
uma das maneiras seria isso para nós
podermos registrar a a história de um
povo tão sofrida
quando você diz a o povo aí eu pertenço
eu não pertenço um povo ou eu não sou
indígena não brasil é um pouco de
miscigenação muito forte então eu posso
dizer que eu não tenho uma mistura
quando há mais de cem anos atrás quando
meu pai me observou tiver como eu vou
tiveram contato com a sociedade não
indígena
tá eles vieram do mato então eu não
tenho mistura nenhum agora já meus
filhos têm estilo tem uma mistura de
sangue europeu
então é isso vamos pensar em conjunto
convido vocês tá vamos pensar de que
forma nós vamos fazer estou à disposição
como pesquisador de uma linguagem a
então nós podemos pensar em criar um
programa específico para esses povos
indígenas
a nível nacional eu convido isso repito
novamente
eu vou me manter em contato na já que
nós estamos hoje também já quero
agradecer esse convite já está falando e
essa da minha preocupação sobre manter
vivo uma história uma
língua tá que a internet a tecnologia de
informação está ocupando o espaço desde
dessa nova geração
eu agradeço essa oportunidade e obrigado
[Aplausos]